somehow five years later
covet hits
and you know what they decide to do
they're like
you know what let's go all in on
creating like safety safety stuff for
covert like masks respirators
um gloves things like that and they
become one of the like core providers
right at the start of covet they shifted
all their production manufacturing stuff
they're like forget the vodka bottles
forget the LED screens
we need n95 masks and we need
respirators and we need you know these
testing kits and we need and they
started producing this stuff and they
started just winning all these contracts
[Music]
we're live Sean uh we have a bunch of
stuff you you have a you have a a full
menu over here and so do I yeah all
right I want you to look at my menu here
and I want you to just pick something
off the menu go ahead and I'll Riff Off
it we don't prefer people who they don't
they don't know we only write like one
or two words so you get like a teaser
you're like man what the hell is this
about but you don't know what it
actually is
but I have I put all my stuff in here an
accident I have this new researcher
who's crushing it he just gives me all
the content like five minutes ahead of
time but uh Rich neighbor
how did I know you'd pick a rich
neighbor so there's somebody in my
neighborhood who I bumped into and
I've just I'm you know I sort of get out
there and I collect signals is this you
know where where do I place this person
on the uh the Billy scale like are they
you know are they on their way up are
they are they have they made it in life
are they really balling out of control
where where is this person these people
have been balling out of control like
when Christmas time came up
there was just like the wife went
outside and it was just pointing at
windows and all of a sudden the house
was lit up like a Christmas tree they
had like so they had almost like decked
out things and they go hey hey um invite
your kids over uh this Thursday we have
a snow machine they're we're building a
Snow Hill in our driveway like uh you
you want to do sledding without going to
Tahoe what's that like a big snow cone
is that what that no it's like a giant
truck that comes that creates snow and
it piles it up so that your like their
house looked like it was in you know
Michigan or something like that yeah but
it's just like like it's like an ice
machine or something yeah it's like yeah
something like that yeah like a big snow
cone like a big shaved ice thing yeah
yeah you were right from the from the
beginning you're right so they did this
and they had a fake Santa there and I
was like man this is a lot for a
Thursday afternoon but okay uh this is
cool like these people's style they seem
really nice and I didn't know what they
did so I kind of I hit it with the
Google the other day and I was like
let's see who these people are
and they have a crazy story so they
created a company
that back in 2014 did this thing it
basically it lets you take a vodka
bottle they had a vodka bottle that had
an LED sign going around it so you could
give somebody a vodka bottle that would
say happy birthday Sam or like you could
program any message I could be like you
know uh whatever I could be like you're
getting an old [__] whatever I could
write any message on it it would go on
your your vodka bottle all right seems
kind of gimmicky I don't really you know
not a bad idea but but balling out of
control from that didn't didn't 100 make
sense but that was it sounds like a Drop
Shipping like joke sounds like my first
idea out of college it's like this is
like me in college would have been like
bro
next next Google I got it
what if we took you know this Jager bomb
and we put an LED screen on it wouldn't
that be incredible and so so they had
this thing and they were like licensing
this out or something like that somehow
like Shaq became an advisor to their
company it was really crazy it makes
sense yeah as you would
five years later
covet hits
and
you know what they decide to do they're
like
you know what [__] this vodka thing
let's go all in on creating like safety
safety stuff for cover like masks
respirators
um gloves things like that and they
become one of the like core providers
right at the start of covert they
shifted all their production
manufacturing stuff they're like forget
the vodka bottles forget the LED screens
we need n95 masks and we need
respirators and we need you know these
testing kits and we need and they
started producing this stuff and they
started just winning all these contracts
and so now like if you go look at their
website it's one of those I know your
Rich websites because there's like not a
lot of information on it but if you go
to like the P they have like a press
release section and it's like PR
Newswire company gets 113 million dollar
contract with the government for safety
equipment oh my God local East Bay
success story where they uh they're now
the the sole testing provider for you
know with the Lakers Stadium Levi's
Stadium like all these different places
and so these guys are getting 100
million dollar plus contracts for their
stuff now I think probably it's like
you know probably only like 10 margin
when you buy you think it's that selling
masks I think for things like that
probably it's like 10 15 is my guess
maybe maybe during coven everyone was
completely price insensitive and they
could just charge whatever they wanted
I'm not sure I would have thought that
but um
but wow dude what a what a pivot and uh
you know that isn't that just kind of
crazy and that was an opportunity kind
of available to a lot of people right
dude I know a bunch of people who did
that and like I had a friend that did it
and he's like dude check this out and he
sends me a picture of a Shopify store
and it's doing like 2 million a month I
know a lot of people who did that and
I've only followed up with one or two of
them and uh I have a feeling that like
of the eight people I know who did it
like three of them it worked out and
then the rest it was like a really quick
cash grab but then they over bought
inventory and it and it's like nothing
do you know people who did that yes we
there was a guy in um I had started this
Mastermind group that's actually where I
found Ben uh but like one of the other
guys in The Mastermind group he like
every time we came to the testimony does
he live in Texas no he's in Canada every
time he came to the Mastermind group I
feel like he had a different business
which is like not what you want in a
mastermind group but he was a good dude
and he would always be like oh I have
this other business that's like oh you
know for auto repair blah blah we do
their SEO and I was like okay but then
what about that thing you told me last
time and then one time you came
dude we're doing mobile covet testing
trucks that will drive up to places and
we can just do rapid testing for covet
and we were like all right I mean that
sounds cool but like are you like do you
know anything about covet testing like
does anybody in the world know about
this like what he's like oh I got the
scientist that's going to be great
and then he came back and he was like
hey um really excited to be here I need
you guys help um like three months later
he was like I really need you guys help
about going public and I was like and
he's like yeah we're gonna do like 85
million this year in revenue and I was
like what and he's like yeah we're
getting all these contracts with the
state of uh with like the you know the
[__] in Canada like these country
Country-Wide contracts and um you know
yeah we think maybe we should take this
public next year and I was like oh my
God so how did it end I I don't even
know because I that that guy my head was
just spinning every time uh you know he
would talk because I'm like this is
either too good to be true or I'm too
dumb and this is amazing and I can't
tell which one it is it's probably some
mix of both but you're right I know
several people that went all in on covid
right when it happened and like low-key
got like an absurd amount of traction
very very fast yeah like a ton
my dad had actually called me one day
and he goes
my friend works at this hospital they
need extra equipment they need extra
masks I talked to somebody in India and
they could produce these masks and like
I think we could do like a two or three
million dollar contract
and I was like fantastic
um should do it and he's like yeah I
wanna but my dad has this problem where
my dad is addicted to meetings like he
thinks winning is like this important
person met with me and then he'll tell
me the duration of the meeting to show
me the value he's like only scheduled
for one hour but we sat there for 90
minutes and I'd be like okay so what
like everybody so you know he was really
interested two hours right and he was
just like he just like always just
obsessed with that so he was he just had
a bunch of meetings and I was like Dad
you're gonna
it's all about that action boss you're
gonna take some action here what what's
gonna happen like go go for it do it and
he's like well no I want he's like I
want everybody to like sign off on it
and de-risk it completely pay me up
front and I was just like dude this is
this is like
the cheap way to do business like you
got to take a little risk here
you're throwing shade on your dad right
now I hope he doesn't listen to this and
you called him boss if I said Cosby boss
he's getting in the headlock
yeah my dad yeah we make fun of each
other like we call it like it is I do a
bunch of dumb things and I say when I do
dumb things this is his dumb thing he is
high planning low action on these things
and he says it all the time like um
we went I went I took him to Tony
Robbins and Tony Robbins is all about
like taking massive action on like the
things you want and he's like I was like
what's your big takeaway he's like oh
man I need to take Massive Action and I
was like that yeah that's that you did
it you learned the right lesson from
this thing he goes that's my problem I
don't take Massive Action I was like
whoa he started slipping back into like
basically he's like I've identified my
problem
just like so right so true
whatever it worked out for him yeah he
did he did great like right for like
Village in India to like live in like
owning multiple homes dude the story
great the story of you tell of your mom
of like I think you said she like had
never eaten with a fork or something and
she just comes to America when she's 17.
is that what you said I'm not
exaggerating
I thought you said I thought you said
like she had they didn't use like
utensils or she went to a restaurant and
like or she actually you're right you're
right that did happen no I'm not being
disrespectful uh Mrs Perry that's this
is the story it's on record and then
also when she used a pay phone to call
her brother to say that she was in town
she didn't know like that you hang it up
so she like let it hang yeah and then
she she was just crying at the airport
and some guy was like hey uh do you need
help are you okay she's like I need like
my brother's supposed to pick me up I
don't know where he is like just landed
in America and he said you have a phone
number she's like yeah so he that guy
picks up the paper film puts in the
quarters calls the brother tells him hey
she's at Terminal Two she's waiting here
I'm gonna tell her not to move brother
didn't even know oh your flight was
today like you they had no
correspondence like okay oh hang tight
I'll be there and she talks to him and
she's like he's like don't move and then
that guy had left the helper had left
and so she didn't she's like not only
did I know how to use the Payphone I
didn't even understand how do you put
this back and she's like I kind of was
like fiddling with it like kind of like
like trying to get it to stick and I
didn't know what to do I looked around
nobody was there and I just left it
hanging and I walked away she's like
I'll never forget like just feeling so
clueless about the world
um and there's like five stories like
that on her just yeah they got to
America now they have a house in San
Francisco so it worked out that's the uh
that's the American dream
um um all right another topic what do
you got I got a quick one here so I saw
this Tick Tock of this uh Professor uh
some professor at College uh I apologize
to her I don't know her name but um let
me see if I can find it real quick she
basically uh Professor Cooley I don't
know what she's a professor Cooley at
Emory University so shout out to her
basically her she has she teaches
marketing at
um at this college and for her marketing
class she goes all right glass um
if you want to do well in this class you
want to get an A you have one job go
viral on tick tock
all right I'll see you I'll see you in a
few weeks like if you need help you know
we have some maybe maybe some uh we can
talk about what it takes to get there
but like that's how you get a good grade
go viral on Tick Tock awesome how old is
she young looking or older younger
looking
um yeah she looks like you know
she looks like if you were 12 she would
be your friend's mom
um got it all right so something like
that whatever age that is perfect
description
so whatever
so basically uh I thought this was
amazing and it got me thinking like
really
how many more classes at a university
should be taught this way
um so for example like
why isn't there a classic you know why
isn't there a class at school where it's
basically like okay we're gonna have
four lemonade stands on campus break up
into teams you're each gonna run a
lemonade stand like and you know the top
lemonade stand is going to get an A plus
the next one gets a minus B plus B minus
um and if you if you're not able to
break this threshold of sales you fail
and it's like just let them go and do
their thing and let them learn 100 how
it should be or it's like you know maybe
it's the net profit so to learn about
the cost management as well but like
give them you know 500 bucks and be like
go who can run the best lemonade stand
or t-shirt company or whatever it is or
writing on Twitter
um like you know okay it's an English
class should you basically go read
Shakespeare and all the stuff or should
I basically teach you how to do writing
in like the modern day and basically the
cold email newsletter cold email or
Twitter and it's like yeah you need to
grow an audience around whatever topic
you're interested in it could be
The Bachelor it could be World politics
it doesn't matter you pick your topic
but you got to write to an audience on
that and you got to publish first thing
is quantity you got to publish every day
for the next 60 days
um and then the next thing is going to
be quality can you actually grow an
audience can you get you know 50 open
rate on a newsletter with you know a
thousand people on it go figure out how
to do that and so things like this I
feel like would be so much better than
the way that people learn about how to
do real world business today in school
another one would be flipping like uh
everybody you're gonna look under your
desk yep you're starting with this drill
okay everybody's got a drill like your
job is to flip this drill into the most
valuable item you can get by the end of
the semester go and it's like you got to
sell this take the profit buy something
else sell that and like just keep doing
that until you can get to the biggest
thing
dude uh Ramon our friend Ramon his son
goes to a school here in Texas and
he his kid had a class where he had to
go haggle and it was like you have to
get this much of a discount from a
retail store or something like that and
I was like Ah that's awesome that was
awesome it's like great for a 12 year
old so I love that stuff I dude I didn't
have CL when I was all right my
sophomore year of college I was a
division one athlete a runner
nonetheless a runner a Peak physical
condition they'd made me take a aerobic
walking class which was like if you add
up the tuition it was like nine grand or
something like that so I'm on it was
aerobic walking you show up and you go
for a walk so I'm all in favor of this
stuff I think it's awesome like are you
walking at least at like a fast pace why
is it called aerobic walking versus just
walking is that just branding is this
the gym teacher how to justify their
their their pension or their uh salary I
don't know it was the stupidest thing
ever like
it was it was crazy it was crazy to me I
had to take aerobic I remember this it
was ridiculous uh you just like showed
up what do you mean you had to seems
like they don't force you have to get
like these certain amount of credits and
it was like this aerobic walking classes
was your major like PE why why was this
because they make I don't know I don't
remember exactly why I had to do this no
I don't even remember what I majored in
I think just like accounting or business
or something
it wasn't so I left school early so it
was accounting and then I and then I
left school and then I finished online
later and I was like okay you know give
me just give me any diploma that I can
get please
because
um I moved out so I the summer I had to
take like some summer classes and one
extra semester and uh I heard about
Airbnb and I was like that's where it's
at so I wanted out there yeah yeah so
you you know I think I told you this I
had heard about how you applied I didn't
know you were in college and dropped out
for it
I didn't drop out I well I I don't know
if it's technically drop out I just like
quit going and then I finished online
like I couldn't move it to an online
student yeah like I took like some time
off and then I eventually like finished
and I would have to go like to a Kaplan
you know like those Kaplan like testing
centers and I would have to take these
nonsense nonsense tests but basically
there's this famous runner I was runner
at the time and there was a famous
runner named Chris lukasik and he quit
running which wasn't exactly lucrative
but he was like the seventh most fast
fastest Miler ever and he was like I
quit I'm quitting running at my Peak to
join this thing called air bed and
breakfast and I was like what the hell
is that that sounds awesome and so I uh
emailed Joe gebia the founder of Airbnb
and I was like hey uh I I like Airbnb I
came up with this interesting hack that
I think could help you grow uh here it
is and he forwarded it to
it was at the time there was this thing
called rapportive that had just come out
and I built an Excel sheet where you
could type in someone's first name last
name and like their Gmail or their
company name and then it like permutates
and you put into this thing and it tells
you which email is there so not like
that sophistic of a hack at all but it
was like new technology and I emailed
them and in his head he's probably like
this is dumb but like the fact that you
came up with this like whatever we'll
interview you so the interview and so he
puts me to a minion the minion was like
hey do you want to come to the Bay Area
well I don't know who the guy was but
the guy is probably worth a really
underused word I'm gonna start using
that that's an amazing slander I love it
well that minion is probably worth 20
million dollars I mean you know because
at the time they were only like 200
people and the guy who he referred me to
was like the 17th employee and so his
name was Justin I'm still friends with
him sorry Justin call you minion but
maybe you were like that's your friend
I'm friendly with them but he uh they uh
they go all right great do you live in
the Bay Area and I was in Tennessee at
the time I didn't know what the hell the
Bay Area was when he said I had never
been west of Missouri I'd only basically
been to like Missouri and then like
whatever the states are when you drive
to like Destin Florida for like spring
break those are like the only places
that I'd been and he goes are you in the
Bay Area and I was like of course yeah
it goes great come into my office on
Monday so it's like [__] I gotta get out
there I gotta figure out what the hell
the Bay Area is I thought it was La so I
pack up like
yeah like Silicon Valley I heard someone
make a joke about Silicone Valley but
that was like where like porn is I think
in L.A I I they're all the same to me I
didn't know and so I Googled what the
hell the Bay Area is and I bought a
ticket and I flew out there and I
interviewed with him on a Monday and a
Tuesday and then I interviewed with Joe
the founder he probably didn't even
remember me because it was like a 10
minute interview and then I go home on a
Wednesday they offered me the job on a
Thursday and then a week later I I
called my mom I go dude I got this job
this is awesome and they go what the
hell is this you stay at someone's home
I go yeah I think it's gonna be legit
she goes it sounds like a multi-level
marketing scheme and I'm like well they
have like health insurance and she goes
whatever and so my mom drove down and
packed up my apartment with me and then
shipped me off and like she like gave me
a thousand dollars and that was my seed
money so I moved out there and this was
all in like a three-week span the Sunday
night before I'm supposed to start they
call me and they go we busted you man
you lied about your resume because you
have a criminal record at the time I'd
gotten arrested uh for DUI and I was
like well technically like I'm still
like the trial's still happening so like
I didn't get convicted yet and they're
like yeah but that was it isn't until
proven guilty yeah they're like but that
was sneaky like we asked you if you've
been charged or whatever and I was like
you're right I'm sorry so I didn't
actually get the job I was hired for
like a second but I never had my first
day and then fast over two years later
my wife ends up going to work there and
I remember walking around I'm like uh my
alma mater my old Stompy grounds so I
never ended up working there but I had a
job there for like you know a few
minutes and uh you know it could have
been something great I would think I
would have been like employee 200 I
don't know maybe I would have made some
money or not but that's the story of
Airbnb
that's an amazing story I love that and
while out there I also had to like take
these classes and I remember I didn't
have any money I had the thousand
dollars that was my my money and I used
to have to take this bike and I lived in
the dog patch in a warehouse that was
900 a month and I asked her right I live
in San Francisco they're like he lived
in a dog patch warehouse It's called Dog
Patch it's like uh real part of San
Francisco by the water and I used to
have to ride my bike because I didn't
have any money and I had to ride a bike
that I took for my roommate all the way
up to Twin Peaks to go to the Kaplan
like place which is like six miles away
literally up the steepest Hills in San
Francisco and so I used to have to do
those classes and take tests for like
months it was horrible but it worked out
and now you're here incredible and now
dude I used to uh like I like I I
learned how to like get get rid of like
you could jump on the bus and like when
they they would catch you all the time
and they'd be like where do you live and
I'd be like I don't know uh what's your
name and I just like give a name and
they're like do you have any ID on you
I'm like no I don't have ID and so I
remember like there was Zero countries
there's zero consequences there are zero
consequences I mean That's how little I
had like I didn't have cash for a bus
fare which is 250 but uh uh yeah it
turned out okay
what did you do to uh to grow that
thousand how did you not just wipe out
like because thousand dollars doesn't
get you very far in San Francisco so how
did you not wipe out in three months on
my so when I went to the interview for
Airbnb I stayed at the cheapest Airbnb
there was which was a bedroom in this
guy's house and he had told me he was
starting a business and so when I moved
back out there I go hey dude uh I don't
have a job anymore can I join you I only
have like two or three weeks of like
payment and then and uh my mother and
father had given me a pickup truck for
college and I asked them to sell that
and they sold it so they gave me four
thousand so I was like all right I got
like three weeks of rent or three weeks
of like living expenses now I just got
this influx of four or five grand
um I've got like six months of cash
let's do this and and so I started I
co-founded a a company with this guy a
roommate matching company where we would
uh post ads on Craigslist saying we were
hosting these roommate parties where we
would match people up into three and
four bedroom apartments because normally
it's like uh you're a single person who
just moved there don't know anyone so
you got to move into a existing bedroom
and there's lots of competition so we
would post fake existing bedrooms and
get 300 people to apply on Craigslist
and be like hey this doesn't exist but
we'll team you up with 200 other people
who Wanna the same [__] as you and we
would host these parties and we would
charge people money to attend those
parties and after they got an apartment
and so we basically spun that up on
Weebly and made money right away and
that's how I lived amazing uh wow great
stories I love this uh I feel like yeah
I feel like there's a bunch of I've
heard bits of these but not all of them
uh this is great and I would ride my
bike to like collect these money I would
knock on their door after they got the
apartment I'm like hey you got my money
it was ridiculous
uh that's so good
uh after this I have to go get a hearing
aid and uh I'm gonna get fitted for one
and I have to tell you why I forgot to
tell you this we are at the Vancouver
thing and there is these two women
speaking to me afterwards foreign
and it was loud so like the problem with
my hearing is I can't hear the
difference between background noise and
the person speaking for me it's hard to
tell the difference and these women were
talking to me and you probably noticed
this I lean in hard so I'm only deaf in
one ear but I lean in I lean I turn and
I and I I get really close to you and
also it was just super loud After Party
by the way it was like it was like a
club it was like a club it was loud and
I also stare at people's lips so I I'll
either stare at your mouth or I'll lean
in Mr really signals over here the
horrible worst signals at this moment
comes up to me and I'm leading in and
like I'm starting to get really close
and I can tell she's really
uncomfortable and I I go oh I I'm sorry
I forgot to tell you I I'm deaf I can't
freaking hear you that's why I'm leaning
in so hard and uh it was at that point I
was I told Sarah I was like I gotta go I
gotta get a hearing aid I can't I'm
making people uncomfortable this is why
you bring your wife with you to all
events just to like you know totally
totally make it clear what's happening
here dude and I a rule I don't I don't
travel alone I love having her around
when I travel but that is that's
definitely the icing on the cake is
having around for that reason yeah yeah
you you did the opposite of the
billionaire hug you like you went in
with the with the Brooke boy lean yeah
the broke point lead I'm just staring at
her lips and she says I literally tried
to watch as the words come out of her
mouth and just staring go down her lips
and looking and then leaning in and oh
man I can tell she was uncomfortable I
was like oh I forgot to tell you I can't
hear so I'm gonna go get one of those
things did you ever learn that like
trick from this might be it might have
been in like those pickup artist things
I'm not 100 sure but you're looking at
their the triangle yeah yeah yeah like
the third eye or something like that no
no it's if you ever wanted if you want
somebody to want to kiss you you're
close if you let's say you're close
you're in range and you want to like
kind of almost like hack their little
like biology and get them to want to
kiss you you you do this like triangle
so you basically look at one eye
the second I
down to the lips back to the first eye
so he makes it it traces like a little
triangle and if you do that you'll just
see immediately the person just pucker
up maybe yeah right it just happens
um yeah right I don't know if it's
because you're signaling that you want
to kiss them or that it just makes them
want to kiss you but this [__] works
this was like in college I was like you
know you would have thought I'm in the
Illuminati how many triangles I was
throwing up everywhere because I was
like this is like a magic trick this
thing is amazing did you get any girls
in college probably you're really
charismatic King baby
you had a good batting average but not a
home run got that lead off never got a
second yeah
oh well that's good the hard part two is
my roommate was like
um just unbelievably good with girls and
so he's really good looking good looking
guy and he was right here right yeah
Trevor he's an athlete and he's just
like a professional flirt and so somehow
this guy was just pulling crazy people
like you know you have like an RA who's
like the the person who's like four
years older that lives in the Freshman
dorm
he just started dating the Ra's
girlfriend and then like you know he
started dating this girl on the
basketball team and started dating like
all these seniors started dating this
like one really rich girl who's giving
him gifts all the time I was like I
don't know what's happening here but
like
um you know this guy's definitely
sucking up all the the alpha male energy
in this room and uh you know I'm just
sort of here along for the ride but it's
okay it turned out all right uh well you
know you worked out all right by the way
my dating life was a lot like my startup
life it was basically like fail fail
fail fail fail home run it's like you
know like most people in their career
they sort of get this like 10 raise a
year or whatever where it's like this
linear like steady climb up the ladder
but if you're in the startup world
you're often like making nothing or in
debt or bro and all of a sudden for like
seven eight years and then all of a
sudden you're rich and uh that's what my
dating life was like I was broke for
like 10 years and then all of a sudden I
was rich 100 same it like it didn't it
didn't start picking up until my 20s it
was exactly
you're trying to get what were you
trying to do in your teens bro
I tried I tried a lot trust me I tried I
just I looked like Napoleon Dynamite I I
with braces it just didn't work out dude
I didn't talk to a girl I was sitting
there reciting lines from The Rock in
WWE when I was in my teens bro I was I
was jumping off the top rope in my
bedroom trying to you know just I love
wrestling and basketball and stuff I
didn't have time for girls when I was
like 15. it was a numbers game for me I
knew like you know three percent
conversion therefore you know you got to
try a hundred times right yeah you never
want more of attrition to describe it
whatever I it worked out we both it
worked out for both of us before we get
into this we got to remind people there
is a gentleman's agreement except this
time it's different so we have this
thing at this podcast unlike everything
on YouTube and on Spotify and all that
stuff our content actually isn't free
you're only getting this episode for
free if it's your first one and if it's
your second or third one you have to go
do something first what is it they gotta
fire up YouTube
youtube.com YouTube the app whatever it
is and type in my first million they're
gonna see our pretty little faces right
there you don't even have to watch video
just click my first million clip click
subscribe turn the notifications on and
we need we need this this is what we
need right everybody's got needs
food shelter YouTube subscribers these
are your core core Primal needs and we
have ours and uh that's why it's called
the gentleman's agreement we're not on
the other side so you just have to do it
and everyone's doing it lately so you
should do it and that's what we expect
out of view and also do me a huge favor
and actually click follow on the podcast
app and
Spotify because those help us actually
go up the rankings and then we go up the
rankings we get more dopamine and we do
Dumber [__] and that's why we're here so
do that
um I have a story for you so go to
joop.com so it's j u p e Jupe
so it's jupe.com okay they have a slick
looking website so tell me what you see
I see some sort of like Mega tent
Contraption I don't know what this is
this is like some sort of structure it's
like
is this like a like basically like an
outdoor unit that's uh not like
something more than a tent but less than
a house so I met these kinda I met these
guys recently and they're really
fascinating and so basically the one of
the founders he's like this artist type
he's his name's Jeff Wilson and before
this he like wrote a book because he
lived in a dumpster for a year like he
like slept in a dumpster it was like
some like art project as well as like to
show like for what I don't I don't know
I mean he's a wacky interesting guy but
he lived in a dumpster and then he uh
then he started this like prefab house I
guess it was like marketing for like a
pre pre-fabricated homes or something
like that and um they eventually
launched this startup it's called Jupe
and I originally saw it because Gary tan
famous investor billionaire investor
Gary tan made this YouTube video where
he stayed in one of their things and so
basically what it is is it's I don't
know they would be mad if I called it a
tent but it kind of looks like a tent
but basically they ship it to you on in
like a a huge container and you pop it
up and on the inside it's like a fancy
or like a nice mattress and then there's
like a heating and cooling unit and it's
got lighting that's all solar powered
and so it's like a standalone like house
and the way that their business model
works
is you can do one of two things you
could just buy it for 30 grand outright
or you can do a thing where you they
give it to you for free and they take
something like 40 30 to 50 of the
revenue and you rent it out and these
things are renting out and I was like I
don't know man who wants to stay in this
thing and he was like dude we rent them
out for 250 to 500 a night and they're
always booked and they're trying to
pitch it to me to put it on my land and
I'm not sure if I'm gonna do it or not
but they're it's a pretty interesting
thing this year they're supposed to do
like 12 million in revenue and it's
break even and they've deployed 400 of
these things and their future what
they're doing is they've got these guys
that are just buying plots of land and
then putting 15 or 20 of these on there
and then dupe the company if you do the
profit sharing with them
they kind of run it for you so they have
like their own little platform and they
like will help manage the thing for you
but it's pretty fascinating and I've
been thinking about putting one of these
uh on my on my property I'm not sure if
I'm gonna do it or not because I don't
know if I want more work but really
fascinating interesting idea that I came
across I've been loving these ideas
where
you just
make more money off the [__] that you
already have so like I have land and I
was like should I just like put these
all over my place but they look kind of
fascinating and I thought you'd get a
kick out of it yeah I mean these look
super cool and I got a couple credit
because I see a lot of these like
um
like this kind of like I forgot what's
called adus or whatever it's like this
additional dwelling unit or something
um and they're often just like vaporware
it's just a render of something that
looks sick and what I really like is if
you click their Vision tab it opens up a
notion it explains what they're doing
and four times in this thing it just
says here's our thing parentheses not a
render here's what it looks like you
know after it gets delivered here's what
it looks like the next day again not a
render like hey we actually build the
thing it exists this is real this is not
like some futuristic dream
um and so I think that's pretty pretty
pretty amazing this looks super cool I
don't know why you wouldn't do this just
for even like the story so uh I can I
have an update so my I have this
property uh marathonranch.com and you
can see it it's doing like uh anywhere
from 13 to 17 000 a month in gross
revenue and um so it's doing well I'm
like making money on my Airbnb finally I
got like 40 or something like five star
reviews on Airbnb and I finally started
going up the rankings and it's been
really fun to do and so I'm not sure but
I have 20 acres 20 acres of land I'm not
sure if I want to like screw anything up
because dude at my Airbnb I we have like
20 cows so my neighbor his account well
that's true but like people my neighbor
owns these cows and they use our
property and in exchange we pay less
property tax and people like wake up to
like a moving cow because they sleep and
wake they sleep at all my property for
some reason they decided that's the bed
and I don't know if I want to like screw
that up it's like so peaceful going out
there so I don't know if I want to screw
that up by having more units on the
property but uh dude Marathon ranch.com
your photo here you chose the wrong
photo you chose like a not awesome
looking photo for your hero photo then
if you click Gallery you all of a sudden
see all these awesome photos
it's a work in progress my friend it's a
work in progress
Ive it's still in beta yeah it's because
one of the pictures it you couldn't see
the writing anyway it's a whole thing I
gotta fix but uh anyway it's going well
I I always I basically to listeners I
send Sean updates on my Airbnb and he's
like oh that's neat you're making five
percent you're making five percent
return that's that's really that's
lovely what did I tell you you were like
dude this is if this is five percent or
seven percent or seven percent of years
it's great I go and I told you I go I've
lost more money in crypto than you'll
ever make on your Airbnb yeah
somehow that felt like a good statement
to me
that's a man the Airbnb game it's been
fun it sucked for a minute and then once
I started rolling it is pretty dope so
maybe one day you'll you'll be convinced
but right now it's killing it I don't
know if they'll kill it in like June
when it's like 100 degrees but we'll see
to me the only reason I would do this is
the tax benefits if I bought property
um the actual like rental income and or
and or slow real estate appreciation to
me is not worth it especially given the
headache of doing stuff so you said
let's say from a financial investment
it's only been okay but from a like
reward like it's been quite exciting
what is the margin so you say 13k a
month
um gross okay so now we take out what
Airbnb we take out Property Management
we take out utilities we take out what
what how much what's the gross on that
so like a like a record month recently
was like 17 000 but let's round down to
15 000 because that's what it's been
lately so that's gross so I give away so
I own the property outright but I assume
that I have a mortgage so if you assume
that I had a mortgage plus utilities and
taxes that's in the 7 000 range okay um
I don't have that but let's just assume
that I do because I will get one
eventually
um and then property management is 20 of
uh of uh like the 14 000. so if I do 50
if I do 16 000 Revenue three hundred
dollars per stay goes to my cleaner so
whatever that let's just say that's two
thousand so that brings us down to
whatever that is what I say 15 minus two
thousand that's thirteen thousand and
then management gets 20 of that and then
the rest I assume it goes to a a
property um property taxes and a fake
mortgage so all said and done on fifteen
thousand in Revenue I'll walk away with
only three thousand maybe yeah that's
nuts so that means let's see uh we did
we have 15 000 so 20 margins
yeah it's it's not like it's not kids
on the 15.
well but I have depreciation so I'm able
to like save a fair bit there but um
yeah like it's a cash on cash return
it's gonna end up being like
five or somewhere between five and eight
percent but if you assume appreciation
which is a big assumption but I looked
at the trailing 30 Years it'll probably
be a 15 to 20 percent uh annual return
if I own it for like 10 years right so
but that's a big if so that cash on cash
it's only okay it's only okay but I'm
completely hands off and I also like it
and
I've I learned how to do something so I
didn't I didn't do everything I didn't
do everything right here at all I I
think I paid a premium I definitely paid
a premium for the property dude I know
you paid a premium because if I look at
this uh like if I go to the gallery
it's got the kitchen with like the white
everything's like white and like this
one look of wood that
I'm just like a sucker for if it looks
like this I'm like it's a nice place
people yeah we know about construction
they're like this is like cheap and easy
like you know I would walk into a house
and like well this is a good house so
I'm gonna pay a premium for this house
if they're like why because the
countertops are nice and I'm like yeah I
mean look at this it looks fantastic
looks modern and they're like dude
that's that costs nothing like you need
to pay for a location you need to pay
for square footage you need to pay for
all these other things but I'm a sucker
for like just like the countertops but I
have 20 acres and so my my plan my plan
originally before the Market's tanked I
was like I'll put more I'll build more
crap there and then when the Market's
tanked I got cold feet and I was like
well let's just sit on it and just see
what happens and so now I'm just sitting
on it and it's going awesome like it's
it's it's booked constantly and so I'm
happy with it I don't regret it I would
I would do it again
um and I but like I learned it was a lot
of money to like you know it was seven
figures to like get in the game and so I
was [__] nervous as hell right it's
worked out and I've learned how to do it
so now I know more about it so I'm happy
happy
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
all right let me go um I got two blue
collar hustles for you so these are in
the trash in the trash Biz so
um I've heard of two trash misses
recently that I thought were pretty
interesting I wanted to share them with
you I want you to tell me which one you
like better okay so the first one our
buddy Sie Ava told me about this it's
called smash my trash have you ever
heard of this has he told you about this
no but you want to know something funny
I've been very close with cieva for like
12 years now and I don't I still don't
know how to say his last name
[Laughter]
yeah I I just he's in my phone book as
the very first time I ever met him I
just he said he was Russian so he's just
saved as cieva Russia and so I just
assumed he was Cave of Russia I mean
this guy was like in my wedding clothes
save a tall handsome smart yeah I just
called him Adonis yeah first name and
then attributes like visual attributes I
remember you buy Six Pack six three got
it
I have a system and it serves me well
um all right so Stephen was telling me
about this franchise called smash my
trash and so what they do is they
basically imagine a giant like Crane and
so they drive to any business and like
if you've ever been to like we had a
warehouse so our warehouse just produces
like an um like an ungodly amount of
trash just cardboard you don't just burn
it
just be normal so we have Charlie
Charlie burns the trash but like I
forgot at that
um you would have basically a dumpster
and you get charged per like I don't
know like per filling of the dumpster
like how many times you fill the
dumpster and then you call them up and
they come and they empty your dumpster
what smash my trash does is they'll you
sign up for them they drive around
they'll come to your dumpster and they
just take this giant crane arm and just
smash the trash in just compacting it um
they let you get way more volume or less
it takes less fill so it lowers your
trash bill and um you know that could
save you hundreds of dollars every month
if you do this and so basically the cost
of smash my trash should just be less
than the savings that they give you from
having to do less uh less dumpster fills
and so this is like a franchise that
kind of crushes it basically you can run
this with like two guys and the numbers
on this are you invest like I don't know
400k
typically they'll make like a million
dollars a year in revenue and like 300K
of like net income like even a at the
end of the day and so you're getting
like a kind of amazing cash on cash not
not that not that trash returned you
were getting on your Airbnb this is some
real real returns and um and I think
they have I think they have like a [__]
ton of locations I think they have like
160 locations or something like that
um and so that's like they've made
probably 40 50 million dollars in just a
franchise fees just uh franchising this
concept out so I think this is kind of a
like low-key amazing business
it's amazing but there's a big downside
when was the last time you had a blue
collar job do you remember have you ever
had one restaurant yeah when I was
restaurant not 21 yeah what happens at a
restaurant when it closes do you
remember
just Carnage Carnage everyone goes and
gets super screwed up they get drunk you
take pills you get hot you just do all
types of [__] and then hopefully they
show up the next day and there's lots of
like I remember I've you know I've I've
been a janitor before I've worked in
restaurants I've done all this stuff and
there was like particularly in
restaurants there was constant like
issues with this type of person who
works there and it sounds classless but
it is kind of The Facts of my experience
I don't know what do you think the trash
I guess if a trash person has a job
maybe they get up early so and I when I
think of a trash guy I think more of a
Family Guy yeah for some reason I trust
a trash guy like you know
I feel like a trash guy is reliable
dependable
salt of the earth you know like I feel
like it's not the degenerates that
you'll get like I would rather hire any
Trash guy than a barista at Starbucks
right like I feel like the Barista is a
flake and we never know what's gonna
happen but well the worst is is is like
a bartender yeah or a waiter at a fancy
like nighttime restaurant like a like a
like a or like a like a
TGI Fridays like you know what I'm
saying like the worst of the worst
there's someone out there right now
listening to this that is a waiter at TG
Fridays it just slam their phone in
disgust dude I've worked at all these
places I've worked at all these places
and like this is probably why I had a
little bit of a habit it's I don't know
man this is the downside of if you have
unlimited access to loaded nachos then
something just happens to you yeah yeah
like the blooming onion it's like uh
it's like it's like the full moon you
know what I'm saying like I turned into
a werewolf if I get that every night you
know like it's it's bad I try to do like
a like a Guns and Roses after party like
I'm going wild I'm throwing furniture
out the window so uh yeah is this cool
yes I think there's a lot of headache
and I would be curious we have a good
friend uh or I'm I think you're friends
with them his name's Brian Brian uh
scudimore or scuttlemore he owns um
sounds like a good friend
got junk and Brian has been on the Pod
and uh he uh I don't know if maybe I
could say this but the company's 100
bootstrapped Revenue this is public
Revenue I think is in the 300 to 50 350
million dollar a year range he owns 100
of it he parlayed that now they own like
a painting business and they do all
these like Services I would be curious
what he would have to say is like his
trash guys like or his franchisees are
like degenerates or not and like what's
the headache with those type of people
we should definitely ask him I feel like
uh I feel like he's gonna give his sign
off on this so so this is one trash idea
the other one comes from Twitter I gotta
give credit to Mobile Home Park guy
um I I know the guy behind us he's
actually pretty awesome but I don't know
if he's trying to be public with his
identity here but he's part of our our
guy Mafia right we got the the
restaurant front guy we got the car
dealership guy now we have a mobile home
park guy
and he goes I just found this trash
business that is called bin scrub and
what they do is they clean off your
trash cans so they wash the power wash
your trash cans because everybody's
trash cans are filthy he's like
he's like here's how I would take this
business and turn it into you know six
figures a year of profit
he goes why do I love this business so
everybody's got trash bins so you know
your Market is every home
um it's a very young industry low Market
penetration so you'll probably be the
only person offering this service is not
like a bunch of competitors yet
um you just need one truck and some
hustle uh in a post-covered world
there's lots of germaphobes and you can
play on that and this has like word of
mouth virality so you know this has like
public virality you can see the actual
service being done and so he goes so he
goes you've got to buy a truck the
trucks are about 40K but it's a hard
asset you're going to be able to get a
loan against this so you might only have
to put down five or ten thousand dollars
and get a bank to finance the rest
because the truck will do this
um he goes now here's how I how is
here's how I juice this business to make
it more more valuable hey guys we're
gonna make it make this like the ice
cream truck we're gonna put a speaker
system on top and every time we're
coming around your neighborhood we're
playing the same song He's like you know
I'm going with Outcast So Fresh So Clean
just like just because it's a pun and
he's like we're gonna play this every
single time this song is our branding
we're gonna drive around from 3 P.M to 8
PM when people are home from school home
from work and they can look out the
window and be like what is that and then
they will they will see us power washing
someone in their neighborhood's bins
you can even it's like a horrible idea
hold on hold on hold on he goes
um he goes we're gonna we're gonna like
basically leave little flyer brochures
on top of everyone's bin so when they
take out the trash they're gonna see
that you know this trash can is dirty we
clean them out we we leave your trash
can so clean you could eat cereal from
it and he's like that would be my he's
like my I put a spoon in it be like
you're so clean you could eat cereal out
of this
um so he's like that's what I would do
for my marketing he goes I think one
truck can do about 100 to 200 homes a
day it's a few thousand dollars a day
per truck in Revenue
um you'll use that to finance the second
truck your costs are gas water
maintenance some chemicals assuming
you're the one doing the truck and he's
basically like this is a blue collar
side hustle if somebody wants to
themselves get out there and get to that
10K a month of of income uh that they
may not be able to get out of their job
this is this is his idea so he goes what
do you think fella so Sam you said it's
a horrible idea tell me why
uh okay so completely uneducated here so
two doubts uh I don't think that you can
do I I don't think that that many people
would want this and number two 100 to
200 a day that's so many that is so many
I would how much it would take 20
minutes to drive somewhere I don't that
math is wild to me
yeah you'd basically have to get to a
like dense area and then and then do a
route but that would kind of assume that
they're all your customers which they're
not gonna all because your customers at
the start
did he call us out and say what do we
think no but oh you know he listens to
the Pod so
uh by the way there's two people there's
two people in the comments here one
um sparkling bins business they make the
trucks so there's a woman in the
comments goes it's a fantastic business
we've been we manufactured the trucks
it's been going great since 2020 and
then another guy goes um
yeah I do this mine's called bin Busters
I'm two years in it's going great okay
well I mean what the hell do I know and
by the way that guy his bio says living
the American dream
uh good good for him he's this is their
dream and they're they're pulling it off
uh uh I don't know man I'm out I'm out
in this one I don't want to do this it
was like start a newsletter yeah start a
newsletter dude I uh I I I've people
make fun of me because I bring this up
so much I had hot dog stands whatever
but I used to work with my hands outside
it's so hard man it is so you said you
were a janitor when were you a janitor
uh when I was in eighth grade I worked
at a bakery and it was my job to like
mop the floors take out the trash clean
the dishes and so that was like my first
job six dollars an hour and then uh yeah
that's what I did dude I am so mad at my
parents for never giving me my my my
grind story
like can I you didn't do anything
hardship yeah like yeah you ain't
gangster at all I mean an Uncle's store
for a month and just just give me that
story five dollars an hour and I had to
empty the trash like nobody knows how
long I did it like I got nothing dude I
grew a lot of Asia parents don't want
you to do that they say do your home
hands got no calluses yeah and my kids
I'm gonna give them one hustle story you
know they're gonna have some
very token small hardship that will
sound good later when they make it
because you need that story and I I just
don't have it a lot of my Indian friends
which I have a ton they their parents
were like you don't even clean your room
just do your homework just study is that
what they said to you like like don't
cook don't clean just study well they
didn't say it like that but I wasn't
asking to cook or clean so it just never
came up and they were like yeah your
your job is to study and do good in
school so you can get like a good job
don't go be a janitor and I was like
dude I did it all man I did the janitor
stuff I was a waiter I was a busboy I
was a valet driver I did it all man and
uh I'm happy I did it but uh I don't
want to do it anymore
oh and by the way I need to redeem
myself I made fun of like
the someone the other day said the
retail class so this is like the the
blue collar class but uh I read this
there was this funny article on Business
Insider it had the worst but hilarious
title and it was I'm a millennial
manager who works with Gen Z and then
said like Colin with Gen Z workers they
have a lot of feelings and so look
you're either gonna like somebody you're
gonna have drug issues work with one
group of people or you're just gonna
have to talk forever about like bringing
your whole self to work and all that
nonsense so like we all have our faults
we're all screwed you know what I'm
saying I hate when people say bring your
whole self to work I'm okay with you
just bringing your work self to work
that's cool too you don't have to prefer
that yeah I prefer that if you want to
bring a little bit more of yourself we
could talk about that too but like you
know it's not a mandatory you don't have
to bring your whole self right I'm okay
with just your work self so we all every
every every class and every generation
has issues so I don't mean to throw
shade just at one
um we throw shade at all here we're at
equal opportunity shade thrower yeah Dad
Sam is the trash man
I'll make fun of myself someone made fun
of me the other day because I've got
these surgeries on my ear I was talking
about my ear and my glasses sit funny I
don't know if you notice my glasses sit
crooked because like it's my ear and
someone said uh it looks like Sam got
brain Sam got head surgery didn't pay
for him to put the rest of it back in
because of his glasses are sick
and I was like no that's kind of kind of
accurate yeah
yeah you're kind of there
um dude I told you the other day I want
to tell you about a media company that
most people have no idea about but they
kind of killed it and I love it so I
told you the other day about about
parcast I tell you about parcast yeah
yeah this was the uh podcast Network
that was doing True Crime stuff yeah so
I learned about the story I think the
guy who started just tweeted saying that
he was done at Spotify so I guess his or
not is up but listen to this so it was a
three-year-old uh startup that sold for
50 million dollars to uh Spotify and the
way it started was the guy his name was
Max Cutler at the time his 27 year old
graduate and he bootstrapped this thing
his dad worked in radio I don't think
his dad was like a rich guy I think his
dad uh Ron Cutler I think he was like a
uh he was a radio broadcaster so he had
industry but I don't think he was like
in the business type of thing and he uh
they bootstrapped this thing and by 2018
it's only two years in they had 16 shows
with a hundred million downloads by 2019
they had 40 weekly shows now they have a
staff of something like 150 of which 75
of them are voice actors and I listen to
these it's so weird I listen to these
every night when I go to bed
so like I've got like my favorites I
listened to one called serial killers
there's another one called deathbed
confessions and there's another one
called like murder couples which is
about Bonnie and Clyde there's another
one like it's like all these things and
there's
and it's not like our podcast at all
there's zero riffing and it's like voice
actors see we should just make up fake
True Crime shows like stabbed but not
dead yet
the black guy yeah I just
just like stories that people just got
mind of her was it really an accident
yeah spit on by a homeless guy stories
of NYC
exactly
not injured but it was gross yeah
barely assault uh
you hurt my feelings True Crime Thrills
dude and but like this is the reason why
I like this is
it's not like uh it's like they're just
like you know how weird talking about
like people who do things beautifully
done like you know uh This American Life
and it's like thoughtful it's like
thoughtful like today on This American
Life we're gonna talk about like the
opioid crisis and they like go out and
interview people this is not that it's
just someone who read a book summarized
it and then is reading it and they pump
out like literally one a day and they
have like uh you know 40 shows in that
40 shows now and it's just a volume play
and this guy was like dude this true
crime [__] to Their audience is 75 women
and then me uh and they're they're like
Their audience like it's crack it's
crack to me I cannot stop listening to
this [__] and it's the same thing every
single day you know it's kind of like
Family Guy you know Family Guy they've
been doing it for like 25 years now it's
the same [__] all the time
it works every time I'm gonna watch it
every single time it's just like that
it's the same shtick over and over and
over again and they were acquired it was
they required for something like 53
million or 54 million dollars in cash
and then like another 50 million in earn
out but pretty fascinating this guy
bootstrapped this and they're not
popular on social 20 000 followers
Twitter 36 on Facebook 50 000 on
Instagram they just dominated like
people searching for their their one
podcast is called serial killers that's
all it's called and they just like
dominate when people search these so
it's like long tail it's like what's the
difference what's SEO for podcasts peo I
don't know uh and they just crushed it
really fascinating business and I
brought that up so I did it I hadn't
done the proper research I needed to
kind of close that Loop
you know there's a we had talked about
the beautifully done like you know just
X but beautifully done there's another
version of that that we haven't talked
about and uh I don't know I don't know
about you but like when I was growing up
like if I had like a plate of food and
it's like let's say it's I had a bunch
of veggies I had a broccoli a brussels
sprouts stuff like that I didn't really
want it I was kind of like tired of
eating it but it's still there and I
know I should eat it
um me and my sister used to have this
thing where if one of us was like in
that that spot where we wanted it we
know we should do this but oh God just
the idea of sitting here for another 20
minutes just spoon after spoon of this
that's I just can't bring myself to do
it one of us would look at the other and
just say Savage just Savage you start to
eat just like an absolute animal and you
in like 30 seconds you do they say it's
like chugging for food and so um we used
to say that and it would be like all
right we got to Savage it and we would
just quickly down the whole thing now
there's a version of that for businesses
that's kind of what you described here
was this guy was like oh okay people
like this true crime audience pumping
this out
I'm gonna Savage it and so basically in
two years to pump out 40 shows and get a
hundred million downloads there's only
one way to describe that he Savaged it
and it he wasn't trying to be
beautifully done I bet you it's
imperfect in all these different ways
you know he might have been hiring you
know random voice actors and you know
Paraguay and like doing whatever it took
to get these out there and pump them out
but that's exactly what he did and I
think actually way more often than the
beautifully done do you see people just
Savage it and just just scale up like an
absolute Savage because they find
something that works and then they don't
they're not perfectionists and they
don't like um they they don't get
limited by what's the normal Pace
they're like and that works what's the
theoretical limit of this and that works
more I remember when I lived in San
Francisco when I started the hustle I
was like originally I was like let's
just pump out blog posts and people are
like well what about quality over
quantity and I was like dude did you
bring yourself to work again yeah I was
like dude I well I was I would always
turn on I go no our quality is quantity
right like we are not we are not an
article business we are like how many
how how can these operations be where we
pump out lots of Articles that's the
product we're building you're not a
journalist you're a blogger go go blog
it was like and then another that was
always one where like people are always
like quality versus quantity and I'm
like uh you need both or if I want to
play with their heads I'd be like no the
quality is the quantity another thing
where people would say is like uh well
it's a marathon not a Sprint and that
was like a a reason for them to slack
and I'm like yeah but have you ever ran
a marathon at world record Pace it's
gonna feel like a Sprint so like you
know it feels pretty fast when you're
running real like top marathoners we're
running fast so it's gonna feel like a
Sprint uh but yeah this guy is a
quantity over quality guy and I love it
yeah I love it exactly okay I think we
should uh we should wrap it here
that's the pond
[Music]